le question à la colère des français je
condamne sans aucune hésitation à les
violences je suis scandalisé de voir
certains comportements concernant les
agressions d'élus les menaces de mort
tout ça est est tout à fait inacceptable
en revanche je peux comprendre la colère
et je peux comprendre la colère d'autant
plus que je considère qu' on a et on
traite tels des pestiférés une frange de
la population française qui n'est pas
hors la loi les non vaccinés on va les
appeler comme ça puisque c'est un groupe
qui apparaît homogène dans la manière
dont on en parle on a une tendance dans
notre grand et beau pays donc surtout
les débats publics à essentialiser comme
si les non-vaccinés se ressemblaient
tous agissent et tous de la même manière
veut que
les fonctionnaires sont des feignants
les élus sont des voleurs les musulmans
sont des islamistes les jeunes de
banlieue sont des délinquants stocks il
faut arrêter il y en a assez des noms
drac signer la motion tout à fait
respectable il ya des noms date il est
comme je viens de le dire bernard de
queue qui respecte et les gestes
barrière qui sont chez eux qu'ils ne
gagnent rien à personne qui respecte
donc la loi ou et que l'on traite de
citoyens ils responsables à qui l'on dit
puisque je vous considère comme un
citoyen responsable vous n'êtes plus
citoyen mais vous rendez compte que
jusqu'au combat de notre pays n'est pas
assez fracturée pourquoi en rajouter à
la fin quand vous voyez les graphiques
car il vous dira
si les graphiques les graphiques alors
présentation le nom d'actionnaires ce
métal qui ont une parole équilibre et je
les en remercie et qui disent nous on
n'a le serment d'hippocrate désolé maxxi
n'est pas mathieu nous on est là pour
soigner
vous avez des parlementaires j'ai
l'impression que vous balayer d'un
revers de main un peu facilement qui
explique le nom il faut pas que la
sécurité sociale rembourse de qu'il faut
pas aller soigner d'année le maire de
nice monsieur christian estrosi pas plus
tard qu'aujourd'hui il n'est pas
parlementaire une déclaration donc
monsieur ne fait pas semblant non mr
dumas fond blanc une petite est née
rappelé qu'ali monsieur estrosi puisque
en effet ça c'est intéressant
minimiser ses responsables aux
politiques car il me racontait alors
si vous êtes mais dites nous plutôt est
favorable à ce qu indique richard
exposito que nous dire qu'il est pas
parlementaire il a été ministre
parlementaire il est maire de nice
succès rend hommage aux nombreux sommets
et les reconfigurer dans les conditions
qui étaient celles du confinement
général le premier moi je vais vous dire
je suis absolument opposé à sa merci
c'est évidemment moi je vais vous dire
il faut soigner ces scans alliés et les
jeunes et de nombreux pays bas en ait
tendance à parler en des termes
gravissime non vaccinés qui respectent
la loi comme on en parle peut-être avec
plus de dureté que pour des vrais
délinquants
il va falloir remettre un peu les
policiers voulaient pas parler des
graphiques 1 avec harry les graphiques
les graphiques et non mais qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire qu'on revoyait sur les
graphiques
ci robert ce bac je sais qu'il est
honnête de nous confirmer que dans cette
période de l'année kovy doux pas trop
vide on a des services qui sont
embouteillées et on a des choix qui sont
la déprogrammation depuis il y avait une
étude qui était parue dans la presse qui
remonté jusqu'à 2002 de 2002 à
aujourd'hui on me disait orco vide on a
toujours eu des déprogrammations à cette
période de l'année parce qu'on est à un
moment donné je vais pas
ce bug non je veux par dessus des halles
où elle en avait quand même manifester
pour dire qu'on a il y avait quand même
des insuffisances à l'hôpital si c'est
une réalité mais
à cache-cache bon deuxièmement
effectivement en hiver on a une
saturation bon bien pire on est tous les
ans limite la taille et milite donc on
pouvait accuser personne à cette époque
aulas oui maintenant c'est facile de
mettre sur le dos d'un coït mais non en
ce qui concerne en ce qui concerne
j'aime pas le tri mais je préfère le mot
choix il arrive en notre âme et
conscience parfois j'oublie l'aco vide
de dire non à cette personne n'y a
aucune chance vraiment la réanimation
pas parce qu'elle va prendre une place
il ya un moment où on est rationnel on
dit bon cc contre l'acharnement
thérapeutique 1 sauf que aujourd'hui on
est en pousse les murs canton des
programmes au niveau lequel des
programmes et déjà il ya quelques temps
et en des programmes aujourd'hui
j'espère que ça va revenir c'est un
niveau et madame vous avez parlé de
binic même dans les cliniques privées on
a fermé des cliniques privées parce que
vous savez quand on des programmes j'ai
parlé de choses peut être importante
coloscopie prothèse de hanche on dit
madame l'a 75 ans elle a mal ou monsieur
ils ont très très mal il ne marche plus
voyez la souffrance psychologique ça
existe et pas mortel mais c'est donc
retard car en retard dans un mois dans
deux mois dans trois mois maintenant si
vous le permettez il n'y a pas beaucoup
de temps j'en aurais parlé de ce pass
lak si lad alors moi je vais très très
honnête avec vous dès le départ j'étais
pas pour un pass sanitaire j'étais pour
un pass vaccinale dès le mois de juillet
et je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que
j'aime pas on fait ça après on monte à
chaque fois engagée puis d'un coup c'est
fait pas loin de l'obligation
effectivement pourquoi le président a
parlé le 12 juillet oui là il a institué
juste avant saint juin nous avions les
informations sur ce fameux delta ce
fameux variant n'diaye il était arrivé
en grande-bretagne dans certaines villes
et on en avait déjà 25 dans les landes
c'est bien aussi dans le pays basque il
y avait déjà 25 cas de delta et on
savait alors on n'est pas très bon
séquençage on savait que et donc on
savait que ça allait aller très très
vite et que lui lui on savait déjà qu'il
était particulièrement virulent est plus
contagieux que le britannique y en a eu
trois à l'originel d'alpha le
britannique et le delta est maintenant
effectivement nos micros et donc dès le
départ on savait si vous voulez que le
vaccin alors c'est vrai jour une
parenthèse sur le vaccin c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu deux fausses promesses on ne
savait pas au départ on pensait que
c'était un vaccin comme un des émissions
du vaccin qu'il empêche la transmission
ça marche assez bien sur le premier un
peu moins sur le britannique est sur le
delta mais par contre ça marchait sur
les ventes mais madame si on n'avait pas
ce vaccin on en serait on en serait
ensuite pour diallo non simplement terme
marie entend elle terminée dès le départ
maintenant je voulais effectivement
directement impasse vaccinale faé et je
pense que ça aurait évité beaucoup de
contamination mais beaucoup de
l'hospitalisation et beaucoup de morts
parce que le delta il était vraiment
violent